i'm going to show you three things okay
i'm going to show you three pictures i
want you to think with me you know they
kind of like to get these puzzles
sometimes like what's the thing that
what's the thread it goes all the way
through all these three pictures okay so
we're going to try and look at each one
and try and work out what's going on
does anyone hands up recognize like what
does this look like where is it from
specifically an Achilles this is a
picture of the screen at the stock
market at the stock exchange the ASX is
what we call it in this country in
Australian Stock Exchange okay what do
you think these numbers represent what
are they do you think anyone oh yeah
Frank hasn't yet I think I got different
countries Oh was ok so you think about
currency yes so I might be thinking how
many US dollars can i buy with my
Australian dollar or how many euros can
i buy with my etc ok dad might be
something what else might have been
quitting oh [ __ ] how much the share with
ya very good sir I am I bought shares in
Telstra are they doing well today or
they're doing badly you might see like
this green and red those means some
things okay there was picture number one
it sound like a picture of a tune hmm
Mariana Trench who's heard that phrase
before you and heard of the Mariana
Trench can someone tell me something
special about the Mariana Trench what is
special or unique about it does it yeah
very good the very deepest spot on the
bottom of the ocean floor less people
have been to the Mariana Trench that
have walked on the surface of the moon
that's how deep it is okay how to look
at the picture you can see a few things
there you've got the map but then you've
got this guy down here how would you
describe what is this showing yeah
Christian very good I've got kind of
number one where the Titanic it sank and
where it's rich resting depth was and
then you've got this thing what is this
this is the height of Mount Everest
which is what what's significant about
manifest it's the year to go yeah very
good it's the furthest away from sin
and then you can see this is the bottom
of the Mariana Trench it's been ok right
so picture one was the stock exchange
picture to bury our trench here's the
last one okay what are we looking at
look yeah it's a thermometer right now I
want you to look carefully at this
thermometer what temperature is it on
this thermometer it's to ruin what can
you see the mean zoom in a little clean
yeah that looks pretty cold looks pretty
cool to me one and a bit degrees okay I
wonder what you'll notice is it's sort
of there in the middle isn't it like you
could get a lot warmer than that
obviously and you can get a lot cooler
yeah okay stay pictures stock exchange
mariana trench and then this is the
moment of here now don't shout on an
answer I actually want you to pick up a
pen now as you put them down for want
you to pick up a pair and underneath
where you're heading is you don't have
one yet I would like you to drop down an
idea what do you think is the idea the
one concept that links all three of
these pictures together the stock
exchange the Mariana Trench am I was on
like this thermometer jot something down
I want you to fight your own idea first
and then in a minute I'm going to ask
you to turn to the person next to you
and I want you to share with them would
you do that for a minute write down your
idea how'd it go for you all together
for a second you keep your pen in your
hand because I heard a lot of wrong
color I heard a lot of different ideas
I'd like you especially if I came around
to you but even if I did it let's just
get some hands up and shout out like in
a word or like very very brief don't
give me a whole sentence try and boil it
down what did you see as the thread that
combined Australia's lucky shades the
trench and the phenomena we looked at
gin yaad Hannah
Woods Fantine opens fancy words ok we're
going to revisit these words in a second
whatever baby okay thank you very much
jared Darcy do you have different one
okay there's lots of measuring happening
we've seen that numbers are now more
than measuring but these all seem to be
measuring particular things free sandy
oh I saw percentages yeah yeah you can
totally like that yeah well I do you
have a different together comparison yes
I don't put that in you because I heard
someone saying we're measuring things
and then we're comparing them like one
to another okay thank you have a lost
different one ah ok yes you can put all
of these things you could draw them
couldn't you and make a picture of them
okay q ej one more ok I'm going to use
that I'm going to pause there and use
this is my segue into this little
sentence which I have written and I'd
love you too if you have something
equivalent on yours you can finish off
your sentence the way to I'm about to
finish why or you can start a whole new
sentence on your page there in the
Australian Stock Exchange mariana trench
and the phenomena what we encounter what
we need are what I go to numbers that
are and in fact I'm going to use the
Kimmy's exact words okay above and below
yeah a button below above and below what
do you remember when we had a look at
the strange soccer shirt right and you
saw some numbers they were in red and
there are some numbers that they were in
green right bring good red bad we're
talking about like other values getting
better or either now who's getting worse
are they doing smaller okay when we
thought about the Mariana Trench we
thought about everest that goes up and
you got the Mariana Trench goes down and
then you say what's right in the middle
what would you call the middle of that
and then lastly we saw the thermometer
which one there was that middle
temperature which is in fact freezing
point right all of these we can call the
zero on those scales right you could say
I'm at zero meters above sea level
I mean sea level right now ground level
I could say zero degrees Celsius I could
say zero like increase or decrease in
the value of my share so we're
encountering these numbers that are
above and below zero this is the
critical idea that faithfully unlike boy
bands numbers can have more than one
direction right we can have us you can
have down and that's what if you want to
make your hair now that's what we're
looking at in this topic these kinds of
numbers are cool integers integers it's
an interesting choice of name you guys
know I'm obsessed with names and what
they mean is ever knew what integer
comes from yeah what does it mean that's
okay so it's interesting um when it's
not a percentage so for example is yeah
what do you mean yes okay all right um I
think what you're talking about is the
idea that the numbers it's a whole
number sort of thing okay an interesting
way that is where this begins so when we
say someone has integrity right or the
hull of my ship is integral remains in
one piece has it fallen to pieces okay
but interestingly in this context this
is kind of an example of where a word
begins somewhere and then it's me it
grows this isn't actually my idea and
you can put a big box around this if you
like Akamai greeneries this is my
definition for an integer it's a number
that is above or below zero in other
words it's got this direction idea ok
you can have and these are the words
that actually Jared mentioned you can
have positives and negatives positives
are the names we give two numbers that
are above and negatives are the names we
give two numbers that are ball or at
least that's where we begin